okay the notion of wrapping up this
marathon of today was daunting until we
thought oh we can do that ray Goldberg's
name was raised earlier as sort of the
sort of were source of food agriculture
studies and so on at Harvard this is not
just a past activity Ray has been
convening many of us annually around a
most remarkable bringing together of the
not just researchers but researchers
private sector leaders people from the
labor movement the consumer movements
civil society and so on he has I think
in an unparalleled breadth of
perspective on the world food system and
so we could think of no one better than
to tell us what all this means for the
world and for what Harvard does next
regular thank you for being here thank
you Bill and let me congratulate the
group that put this all together as I
SAT listening to it I said to myself I
pray that this becomes an annual event I
also pray that before the next annual
event that each of these speakers
provides a five-year perspective of
their our research so we know they're
where they're going and then we can
relate it to what was said here
we're in the middle of a major
revolution and a doctor church was very
modest and actually didn't finish all
the things he was about to say he was
just recognized recently by creating a
new amino acid a new amino acid that can
be used in crop production to make sure
that pollen drift no longer occurs this
revolution affects everything that these
speakers have talked about everyone
talks about food is part of our culture
part of our beliefs part of our
religions part of our way of life part
of who we really are but the one thing I
found missing is that each of these men
and women who are working at Harvard
don't spend enough time with each other
because we barely have a chance to see
our respective faculty in our own
jurisdictions I think we have to
overcome that the student body has done
a better job than we have in looking at
cross registration at multi disciplines
because that's required for this
industry we talked about the private
public and not-for-profit sectors as if
they were enemies
they aren't we are for the first time
seeing collaborations in both the
developed in the developing world that
never existed before in order to address
the very problems we're all talking
about we haven't the luxury anymore to
find the villains and blame this person
or that person for the problems we face
if nothing else this program has proven
to me that the only way we're going to
address these problems is if the private
public and not-for-profit sectors all
work together and I having been here for
60 years finally have lived long enough
to see them trying to do just that so
congratulations to all of you